[Music]
obviously all of you believe that your
dad would be a great president for this
country but as people with families how
do you feel about your dad becoming
president and how that would change your
life we're nervous about it I mean it's
it's one of those things we our lives
are pretty good as they are and this is
one of those things where we recognize
it's good for the country for my dad to
run but not necessarily he's good for us
and so we we're gonna try and keep our
lives as normal and as as consistent as
they can possibly be over the next few
years well obviously I believe you
wanted him to run in the last campaign
were you guys reluctant about him
running this time we knew what we were
getting into this time and so we're
definitely more hesitant I'm really
reluctant I didn't wanted to do it I
tried to convince him not to I think
there are a few a few of us that tried
that I know you didn't but I just felt
like you know for us as a family this
isn't the best thing but as Josh said
for the country we think it's the right
thing probably tell I really love the
limelight so I was
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]